et oui vous êtes à new york sur la scène
d'un théâtre de broadway
nous on ne changeait pas de chaîne ok
vous conseillez voir la campagne
américaine la maison blanche
mais depuis un an moi c'est cela le jeu
public vous asie de changement ou les
citoyens le peuple dans ce monde si
compliqué nous attendons tous autres
choses des politiques alors aux états
unis un showman l'a bien compris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez reconnu tram donald trump
ce jeune premier en politique de 70 ans
ce chef d'entreprise milliardaire roi de
la téléréalité a fait voler en éclats
les règles de la communication politique
une histoire comme on n'en avait jamais
vu dans une démocratie moderne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donald trump est un showman dit on et il
a compris au delà de toute mesure que
l'élection présidentielle américaine
c'est aussi du show business
hillary clinton est une femme politique
ennuyeuse elle ne déchaîne pas les
foules comme barack obama dans
l'antichambre donald trump a créé de
nouvelles règles la question c'est
est-ce qu'elles peuvent s'appliquer aux
autres échangeront telle la politique
pour toujours
[Musique]
depuis janvier je suis donald trump
comme hillary clinton pendant des mois
il a voyagé seul dans son avion sans
médias sans journalistes et jouant sur
le culte de sa personnalité
j'ai assisté à des dizaines de meetings
trump toujours mis en scène de la même
manière
d'abord nous arrivons dans une petite
salle et nous sommes parqués au fond des
bénévoles locaux est souvent aussi à
fabriquer une belle image
les meilleurs visages repéré dans le
public sont castés pour figurer au
dernier moment derrière le candidat
ce sont souvent des héros du 11
septembre comme ce jour-là en
pennsylvanie un pompier de new york
avant l'arrivée de donald trump
la campagne est aussi diffusée par haut
parleur de la musique
de nombreux artistes ont refusé d'avoir
leurs morceaux joués dans ses meetings
mais qu'importe donald trump a eu une
idée diffuser des airs d'opéra libres de
droits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après l'opéra et en attendant le ténor
de la soirée des chauffeurs de salle
assure la première partie vous n'en avez
pas marre de ces élites qui vous disent
quoi faire qui vous disent quoi dire
qu'ils vous disent quoi penser
[Applaudissements]
elle trop c'est trop
elle n'a trop c'est trop si vous en avez
marre que l'on vous mentent taper des
pieds avec moi
j'entends un train trump est dans la
place
c'est le train de trême pas
le train de trump c'est le train de la
colère qui sillonnent l'amérique de la
classe moyenne depuis des mois ensuite
toujours c'est au tour d'un citoyen
ordinaire de venir témoigner
je n'ai jamais eu aussi peur pour
l'avenir de mes enfants
aujourd'hui
j'ai entendu hillary clinton et obama
ils s'en fichent de dèche
mais pour l'avenir de nos enfants vous
pouvez faire confiance à donald trump
[Musique]
ses meetings
donald trump à une stratégie bien
précise il regroupe des milliers de
personnes et s'assure que tout le pays
le voit dire à ses électeurs
vous n'êtes pas seuls et au final
l'image d'un effet symbolique très
puissant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
régulièrement au fil de la campagne
trump j'ai assisté à des accrochages au
milieu d'un public chauffé à blanc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à une époque donald trump apparaissait
en guest star dans des matchs de catch
les matches et c'est bidon mais lui il
faisait le show aujourd'hui il cherche à
recréer la même ambiance avec ses
meetings
l'ambiance de ces matchs de catch en
organisant ces grands rassemblements et
défilés pic
il promet de grandes choses et surtout
donne un vrai spectacle
c'est très bien mais les téléspectateurs
ne doivent prester ses avoirs
[Applaudissements]
les stratèges d'hillary clinton ont mis
au point une campagne très classique
avec un décor figé et immuable
nous journalistes politiques sommes
toujours tenu à l'écart de la candidate
pendant plus de six mois nous n'aurons
donc aucune possibilité de l'approcher
pour la questionner sur scène un podium
de présidente et un prompteur pour les
discours important souvent présente
cette journaliste politique de nbc news
qui connaît bien il a ri et une
photographe payé par la campagne une des
seules autorisées en coulisses un
dispositif sans faille sous contrôle au
service d'une candidate transformer en
machine politique elle est assez
prévisible un peu raide on peut dire
coincé même patate pkg mais c'est une
femme politique bien au centre ne
propose rien d'extrême
en fait elle suit les traces d'obama
barack obama mais c'est ok c'est normal
mais c'est pas excitant
le problème c'est qu'en face d'elle on a
un candidat qui est prêt à baisser son
pantalon à la moindre occasion
ils sont complètement différents accords
un adage quand elle passe à la télé on
sait déjà ce qu'elle va dire des choses
constructives
est ce que ça fait là une série de sept
jours mais au-delà de ces jeux
analystes préférant série des mains que
répondre à la volée à nos questions
hillary clinton achève toujours ses
meetings par un petit bain de foule et
parfois il y a des surprises
[Musique]
leurs délégués sénatoriaux en somme
cette statue fans souffrance n'est pas
un prédateur
je crois que c'est une femme qui a été
blessée c'est une femme qui par
tempérament est prudente
c'est une femme qui a vu de très près et
autour d'elle les dégâts les fracas de
la vie publique et qui s'en protège à
l'excès elle s'est encore une fois
enfermés dans un personnage fabriqué par
des conseillers en communication avec
probablement trop de répétitions trop de
formules trop de faux rires trop
d'exercices comme on en voit sur les
late show où on est obligé de
s'esclaffer plaisanterie garçons ben
c'est pas son tempérament sous mes yeux
pendant les primaires hillary clinton
est devenue la nouvelle reine de la
communication numérique accessible
souriante et proche du peuple
hillary clinton l'impératrice du sel
fille
[Musique]
une campagne c'est de l'émotion est ce
que la personne est sympathique
est ce qu'elle vous protégera est ce
qu'elle vous ressemble les candidats
répondent à travers leur selphy leurs
vidéos facebook ou leurs tweets et c'est
vrai que les réseaux sociaux sont
essentielles pour leur campagne mais en
même temps nous les journalistes doit
leur rappeler l'enjeu des élections
on n'élit pas un président avec qui on
aimerait voir une guerre mais quelqu'un
capable de prendre des décisions pour
changer nos vies
le 20 juillet dernier je me suis cru au
festival de cannes une star débarque à
cleveland
en starlette aux pics directrice de
communication derrière elle legendre
jason principal conseiller et lui
[Musique]
à gauche mike pence vice présidents
potentiels et derrière la famille trump
ses deux fils et ses deux filles dont
ivan cal a préféré la personne la plus
influente de cette campagne il y a un
nom peu d'observateurs prenait au
sérieux trump la outsiders cette semaine
de juillet il sera sacré candidat du
parti républicain en prime time devant
des millions d'américains
dernière répétition avec comme seul
public
nous les journalistes qu'il méprise
temps trump a toujours le bon mot quatre
jours de spectacles pardon de
conventions cinquante mille militants
une production républicaine à 110
millions de dollars
et pour démarrer un classique américain
toi
s
m
à chaque convention ont pris pour le
bien du pays quel que soit le parti à
cleveland
la nouveauté fut cependant cet invité le
pasteur de donald trump fondateur d'une
chaîne de télévision chrétienne
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
garde t il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un télévangéliste suivi par rodolphe du
liany l'ancien maire de new york et
aussi des vedettes de la télé réalité
comme le chasseur de la série doc
dynastie cette année n'a pas été facile
pour les médias ils se sont trompés sur
toute la ligne
et pendant longtemps france au moins
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai mon idée pour expliquer
comment ils ont raté le train de la
colère c'est peut-être parce qu'il ne
traîne pas avec des gens comme nous des
gens qui aiment chasser pêcher prier et
travailler
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais même pas s'ils savent comment
parler aux gens de l'amérique profonde
sans je leur dis que je viens de
louisiane il me parle créé lentement est
très fort que dieu vous bénisse
30 l'homme c'est une chose mais le
tropisme c'en est une autre
les penguins s'il gagne c'est parce
qu'il a donné la parole à ceux qui ont
l'impression de ne pas être entendu de
telles que nous qui vivons sur les deux
côtes la côte est et la côte ouest c'est
à dire boston ou washington new york
d'un côté los angeles san francisco
seattle de l'autre nous n'écoutons pas
l'amérique du milieu east coast l'ouest
nous l'assurent voulons offrir le gain
plus une grande partie de ces gens
pensent qu'on ne les écoute pas donc on
ne se préoccupe pas deux n'oublie pas
qu'on ne se préoccupe pas de leurs
problèmes d'abord l'immigration est ce
qu'on est allé trop loin
shu et puis le commerce international
avec tous ces traités russe et la
question raciale
ça c'est un problème fondamental a été
traitée que partiellement
[Applaudissements]
au bout de quatre jours de show discours
prière petites phrases étaient les
réalités leroy trump été sacré candidat
officiel du parti républicain un an plus
tôt il était à 6 % dans les sondages
[Applaudissements]
le moment
walchi dreams
winds pro avec son nom ne parle pas de
wonder woman mais bien de la candidate
hillary clinton dans un film commandé
par le parti démocrate à des
réalisateurs d'hollywood
une bio épique produite par la créatrice
de la série scandale hillary clinton a
fourni des images inédites et c'est
l'acteur morgan freeman qui rate cette
belle histoire
[Musique]
à minuit
comme cette superproduction fut le
prélude à la convention démocrate de
philadelphie où tout hollywood se mit au
service de la candidate dans les
premiers rôles sur scène j'ai vu des
stores illuminé
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
il
one of us fismes et téléphone fixe
great and ethics grèce
[Applaudissements]
shiga titre chez sjs caméra suit
understand the taking of spain and
climate change et les zobals et les mots
au big game one à 9
j'attendais cette convention qu'on me
parle de la syrie d'alep et des
problèmes de notre monde
mais voilà les douze plus grandes stars
de broadway était là pour la séquence
émotion
ciao
il
l'amour l'amour repris en choeur par
cinquante mille personnes
alors dans cette parfaite communion le
prince charmant pouvait arriver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
ah mais ma belle famille
bill clinton racontant son amour éternel
pour ilaris pendant la moitié de son
discours
bingo géant pour 53% des électeurs
américains les femmes
[Musique]
et en coulisses on ne perdent rien des
meilleurs souvenirs du couple les matchs
de baseball
la passion d'hillary clinton pour la
danse classique et les fêtes d'halloween
le tout surprendre
[Musique]
il ya un nivellement par le bas des
campagnes présidentielles américaines
qui s'est aggravée après la deuxième
guerre mondiale et surtout au début des
années 70 les campagnes électorales ont
perdu en substance il ne s'agit plus de
politique mais de personnalité il y a la
personnalité du candidat mais aussi le
personnage qu'il joue
ce sont deux choses différentes
il mise tout sur la personnalité une
personnalité qui passe bien à la télé 44
présidents et 44 personnalités en plus
de deux siècles
le 45e locataire de la maison-blanche
sera-t-il une femme la première
apparition d'hillary clinton cet été à
la convention était en tout cas très
attendu et voici que moi elle est
apparue devant ses fans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un moment historique même si la
candidate était à des centaines de
kilomètres de là celle qui a réglé cette
mise en scène virtuelle c'est elle
jennifer palmeraie
êtes vous fiers de ce que vous avez fait
jusqu'à présent yassim un rsa
ça a été une année difficile les
campagnes électorales c'est compliqué le
pays fait face à beaucoup de crise
le combat a été dur
mais je suis confiante pour cet automne
je suis fier du lary chaque jour elle
fait ce qu'elle a à faire
elle se décourage pas et elle continue
d'avancer
pour humaniser hillary clinton jennifer
palmeraie à utiliser des recettes
qu'elle avait appris auprès d'obama à la
maison blanche
exemple ce publi reportage tourné dans
les coulisses par l'équipe de la
campagne avec des moments exclusif
soigneusement choisie est diffusée sur
les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok retour sur scène au direct et au
prompteur avec le discours d'investiture
d'hillary clinton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
servat human rights and sunrise women's
rights and white et les miennes et comme
jan de wilde tron
jason kidd america is great et casam
maraka et gogh 23 ans après être entré à
la maison blanche au côté de son mari
président huit ans après avoir perdu les
primaires face à barack obama tout au
long de cet été hillary clinton a joué
sur une campagne classique
cette convention parfaitement orchestré
aura coûté 130 millions de dollars et
elle était à cette époque en tête des
sondages
toute l'année hillary clinton et donald
trump vont s'affronter sur un thème
sensible l'immigration clandestine la
campagne trump a produit cette publicité
télévisée les syriens nous envahissent
des immigrés inculpés de crimes peuvent
rester chez nous ils touchent des
prestations sociales et passe devant les
américains avec notre frontière grande
ouverte
c'est de pire en pire l'amérique de
donald trump et sur les terroristes et
les criminels notre part la frontière
est bien gardé et nos familles en
sécurité à chaque interview au meeting
donald trump répète aussi les mêmes ou à
220 v en ouest est
construire le mur cela devient trois
mots un slogan politique d'abord urbain
ouah mais ottawa ottawa
belga trois paires varois
3 - un cri de ralliement pour une
amérique inquiète des soubresauts du
monde dans une année secoué par les
attentats donald trump
or ajoute en mélangeant dans ses
publicités les thèmes sensibles de
l'islamophobie et de l'immigration
illégale
[Applaudissements]
les politiciens prétend qu'il s'agit
d'autre chose mais pour donald trump
c'est du terrorisme islamiste radicale
il propose d'interdire temporairement
l'entrée des musulmans aux états unis
jusqu'à ce qu'on comprenne mieux la
situation
il coupera rapidement la tête de dèche
et prendra son pétrole il arrêtera
l'immigration clandestine en
construisant un mur le long de la
frontière que le mexique paiera sur ce
sujet sensible côté clinton on va jouer
plus classiquement sur l'émotion et la
compassion acteurs un repérage d'un bon
moment dans un meeting sur l'émigration
clandestine
[Applaudissements]
ce moment unique d'humanité politique
est devenue ensuite une publicité un
reportage produit par la campagne
clinton et la petite fille sauvée par la
candidate sera récupéré par le service
après vente à la convention démocrate
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et qu'ils veuillent patrons sont en
effet tombés
avec sa maman cette petite fille de 11
ans né à las vegas de parents sans
papiers sera le symbole de l'intégration
avec comme toujours un discours bien
préparés sur prompteur et une petite
phrase choc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant ces mois de campagne
donald trump à saturer les ondes du
matin au soir avec ses phrases chocs
reprise en boucle sur tous les médias
[Musique]
il a créé un nouveau standard par
rapport à ce qui est normalement attendu
d'un candidat à la présidentielle une
pension qu'il y avait une limite de
décence à respecter pour les candidats
sous peine d'avoir des problèmes
il rejette totalement cette limite
délibérément c'est une stratégie
il est bien au delà est pratiquement en
permanence
elle appelle sa défier le politiquement
correct c'est surtout très loin de la
décence habituel 30 et dégagera pas une
couverture plus importante dans les
médias dès le début c'était lui la
meilleure histoire
ils étaient nouveaux en politique
milliardaire businessmen star de la télé
réalité et on n'avait jamais vu
quelqu'un comme lui se porter candidat à
la présidence
il disait des choses surprenantes et
choquante et tous les jours il se
passait quelque chose
il a donc captiver les médias
quotidiennement pour le meilleur ou pour
le pire
la stratégie de donald trump puis simple
dès 7 heures du matin je me réveillais
avec lui donnant des interviews par
téléphone à la télévision
côté people il a aussi reçu chez lui
barbara walters 87 ans journaliste qui
confesse depuis des décennies toutes les
stars barbara invité en exclusivité à
visiter son triplex à 100 millions de
dollars et à recueillir les rares
paroles de son épouse mélanie mais ça
arrive
[Musique]
le soir je me couche est aussi avec
donald trump ont parodié est invité dans
les led chose dont raffole l'amérique
war à votre fantastic
non willy fait il crève l'écran
il le sait et il sait comment faire mais
non j'ai envie d'une petite robe
sollicitait toutes les chaînes de
télévision et était à l'antenne en
permanence et en me trouve les chaînes
étaient ravis de recevoir une robe c'est
de l'audience et donc de l'argent
écoute moi et j'ai le regret de dire que
la plupart de nos campagnes se résume à
l'argent on est dans ce pays où il
n'existe pas de csa ou le temps de
parole des politiques à la télévision
n'est pas réglementée donald trump aura
occupé 800 heures d'antenne sur les
grandes chaînes de janvier à septembre
contre 4 cents à hilard et il aura
économisé ainsi plusieurs centaines de
millions de dollars en publicité
politique
je ne pense pas que la presse est mal
géré cette élection je pense qu'il faut
être indulgent
la presse a appris sur le tas comment
traiter un phénomène comme trump parce
qu'on n'a jamais eu affaire à quelque
chose de ce type
d'un côté on a eu les médias mainstream
qui ont décidé de ne pas être objectif
du tout et de dire c'est terrible on ne
peut pas laisser faire ça et d'autres
qui ont tout fait pour essayer de le
traiter comme un candidat normal on a
vraiment appris sur le tas au fil des
mois les stratèges d'hillary clinton ont
sans cesse scrutés les moindre dérapage
d'un adversaire qui parlent souvent vite
et fort
[Applaudissements]
après cette phrase hillary clinton et
ses conseillers ont donc eu une idée sur
les musulmans
une opération est lancée l'opération
cannes kazire cannes héros militaires
d'origine pakistanaise tués en irak à
l'âge de 27 ans qui laisse une famille
évidemment et flore et les parents kahn
vont alors être invité par les
démocrates a parlé en vedette à la
prévention
le plaidoyer de monsieur can contre le
racisme et l'islamophobie va surprendre
donald trump vous demander aux
américains de vous faire confiance pour
le futur mais je vous le demande vous
avez vous jamais lu la constitution des
états unis
ah oui et non
arrigoni je vous prêterait volontiers
mon exemplaire
enders de raco men
cherchez il est mort lors de recherches
et si les mots liberté égalité des
droits
en quelques minutes monsieur cannes
devient le héros de l'amérique une
minute d'émotion en prime time une arme
politique de destruction massive
mais pour une raison incompréhensible
donald trump décide d'attaquer le héros
s'y expriment les croyants outré par ces
accusations la famille cannes appuyé
bien sûr par l'équipe clinton s'invite
alors sur tous les plateaux télévisés
pendant cinq jours tv cannes remplace tv
treuil donald trump
de plus en plus furieux tweet alors
pendant la nuit
dénonçant l'omniprésence des parents
kahn une grave erreur là aussi de
communication
il ya un profond sentiment patriotique
comme chez la plupart des américains
windows me donald trump s'est non
seulement attaquée à la famille d'un
soldat mort pour notre pays mais il a
continué ensuite à attaquer cette
famille et elle ment alors qu'il aurait
pu s'excuser au moment où le couple kahn
est apparu à la convention démocrate
entre deux mouvements et donald trump
aurait dû dire je suis de tout coeur
avec cette famille à griffes de leurs
fils et aero somme où il a donné sa vie
pour le payer ce n'est plus qu'un tout
simplement excellent mais il ne l'a pas
fait nous sommes en mutinerie ainsi
trump père le soir de l'élection on
pourra dire que sa défaite à commencer
ce jour là
à chacun sa foot dans une campagne toute
erreur peut s'avérer fatale
hillary clinton en tête des sondages cet
été critique alors devant la communauté
gay l'amérique qui votre
après cinq saisons en pro b to b roy m'a
formé avant ce dérapage aussitôt utilisé
par la campagne crom qui ont tant
montrer ainsi le vrai visage de la
candidate de l'establishement des gens
comme vous vous et vous
pitoyable il vous savez ce qui est
pitoyable c'est hillary clinton qui
diabolise cruellement les gens qui
travaillent dur comme vous ce moment a
été catastrophique pour hillary clinton
premièrement ce n'est pas vrai en plus
ses excuses se sont fait attendre mais
quand même et elle n'était pas à la
hauteur
au fil des mois et des 50 états
traversés la machine clinton a commencé
à se gripper la petites pastilles pour
la gorge s'est régulièrement invitée
alors on a commencé à poser des
questions
officiellement tout à l'aide toujours
bien mais cet été on a vu ceci une
quinte de toux de pluie de deux minutes
à cleveland
hillary clinton est incapable de parler
une éternité en politique est une image
qui sera reprise par tous baker
à cette époque c'est la nouvelle
stratège de donald trump kélian conway
qui est à la manoeuvre
elle et d'autres un signe qu hillary
clinton devrait publier son bulletin de
santé
et justement le mixant personnel de tram
s'exprime pour la première fois
publiquement sur la bonne santé de donna
sa santé est excellente en particulier
sa santé mentale
il pense qu'il est le meilleur tout va
bien
[Musique]
le 11 septembre à la sortie des
cérémonies un passant va aussi capturés
sur son téléphone portable
l'image d'une hillary clinton vacillante
[Musique]
donc on la voit chanceler tituber elle
est emmenée dans le temps son fourgon et
des parlers par ses aides de camp
et puis elle disparaît et puis je crois
que ces 45 minutes plus tard on entend à
la tâche et celle ci oui mais pourquoi
est en fait entre je crois 9h45 et 17h30
rien on a pas on sait pas pourquoi et
finalement ils disent ah en fait il ya
deux jours il ya eu diagnose de
pneumonie pour hillary clinton
ils se sont plantés c'était des très
mauvais parce que ça fait que ça a fait
c'est que ça a donné huit heures de
spéculation à l'antenne son rival en
profite
hillary clinton a disparu des écrans
pendant 48 heures alors pendant ce temps
donald trump fait publier son bilan de
santé qui montre que tout va bien et la
même semaine
donald trump s'invite aussi dans les
missions médicales la plus populaire du
pays jeu pour livrer bien sûr en direct
ces examens
surtout quand les deux candidats ont
fait venir leur médecin personnel pour
communiquer sur leur santé on voit qu'il
est en meilleure santé que lui il était
la limite du diabète de l'obésité
il prend des médicaments anti
cholestérol et de l'aspirine pour bébés
pour éviter un problème cardiaque
héréditaire et son père est atteint
d'alzheimer elle elle n'a rien de tout
ça ce jour là elle était déshydratée et
a fait un malaise dû à une pneumonie
en fait elle a une bien meilleure santé
que lui mais il s'est créé l'image d'un
homme fort face à une candidate qui
serait la première femme présidente
elle a donné l'image d'une femme faible
une mauvaise image reprise partout qui
lui a fait du tort ça n'a pas de sens
mais c'est comme ça la guerre des
bulletins de santé fait rage
on comprend grâce aux médecins d'hillary
clinton que la candidate à une sinusite
une infection à l'oreille prend des
antibiotiques mais que sa cliente est
tout à fait capable de devenir
présidente des états unis
[Musique]
trois jours après son malaise
hillary clinton réapparaît enfin
publiquement look bien sûr impeccable et
james brown chantant en fond sonore hype
il vide
la campagne est reparti donald trump
s'est toujours vanté d'aimer les jolies
femmes pendant les années 90 il
organisait les concours miss univers
très médiatisée en 1997 il chaperonne
miss venezuela devenue miss univers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors 19 ans plus tard les limiers de la
campagne clinton enquête sur cette
relation et le 26 septembre lors du
premier débat télévisé
hillary clinton a parfaitement préparé
son attaque
qui compte deux semaines mais ce dernier
quart d'heure l'opération est très bien
orchestrée dès le lendemain dans l'une
des matinales les plus regardées de la
télévision américaine
miss alithia machado enfonce le clou
comment ils vous appelez miss piggy miss
ménages miss machine à manger comme ça
en face mais est tout le temps c'était
normal pour lui furieux d'avoir été
piégé donald trump s'en prend à alicia
sur fox news
[Musique]
cette personne c'était la pire de toutes
les miss univers que nous ayons jamais
eu la pire la pire de toutes
et rome clos la séquence comme
d'habitude par une rafale de tweets
vengeurs dénonçant le manque de jugement
d'hillary clinton
l'équipe clinton réplique avec une
publicité témoignages dali chien en
espagnol à destination de la communauté
hispanique dont la candidate at on
besoin pour se faire élire
[Applaudissements]
il me disait tu es grosse tu es moche il
m'appelait miss piggy miss ménages
je pense sincèrement que donald trump
n'a ni les capacités ni l'expérience ni
la préparation ni les qualités humaines
pour devenir président des états unis
c'est ridicule les mustangs me
boudreault lieu de parler de ce qu'on
devrait faire en afghanistan de l'état
islamique de la syrie mais de ce qu'on
devrait faire pour notre économie qui
est encore fragile
l'otan de prolifération nucléaire
au lieu de parler de ces choses on parle
d'une miss beauté lily à 18 ans de ce
qu'un candidat a fait au pas avec elle
dit ou pas son sujet c'est ridicule
ce sont les règles du jeu de la course
présidentielle
en cette deuxième décennie du 21e siècle
deux semaines après laffaire miss
univers la campagne sombre
définitivement dans un show de télé
réalité les journalistes d'investigation
enquêtes sur le passé de trump ses
affaires ses conquêtes et dans une
concurrence effrénée
le très sérieux washington post sort
l'armé fatale elle était à palm beach et
pour tout te dire j'ai tenté j'ai bien
essayé mais ça a foiré
cela vous j'essayais de la baiser elle
était mariée c'est énorme
j'ai essayé lourdement
elle voulait de nouveaux meubles alors
je les emmenais faire les magasins
gilles paquet j'y suis allée comme un
chien mais j'ai pas réussi parce qu'elle
était mariée
il y à peu je les recroiser elle a même
défaut nichons maintenant elle a
complètement changé de look
les chaude comme la braise oui le donald
assure aux mon pote ou là il faut que je
prenne des tic tac ou cas où je commence
à l'embrasser je suis automatiquement
attirés par les beautés je les embrasse
tout de suite c'est comme un aimant je t
embrasse je n'attend même pas et quand
tu es une star elle te laisse faire
tu fais tout ce que tu veux tout ce que
tu veux tu peux les attraper par la
chatte
tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux et tu
as vu ses jambes
ouais sont belles
salut comment ça va bonjour messieurs
trême comment allez-vous super bien vous
connaissez billy bush a chanté bonjour
vous allez bien ça va merci vous êtes
prêt à jouer en espoirs avec nous sommes
prêts fait de nous des stars cette vidéo
un moment historique dans une campagne
présidentielle américaine un scandale
dans une société puritaine au pays
d'house of cards et pour la première
fois une star d'hollywood incitent à la
violence
genest au même moment donald trump fait
annuler tous ses meetings et se cloître
dans son appartement new yorkais et à
une heure du matin
il présente des excuses publiques sur
son compte facebook et les one of the
world's end à rogers à la fin de cette
campagne après neuf mois passés sur la
route je me suis interdite de vous
montrer de nouvelles femmes révélé à
longueur d'antenne les coucheries de
donald trump bien les emails d'hillary
clinton cajolant hypocritement où wall
street où les révélations du fbi sur
elle
cet automne oui on en avait tous assez
oui les humoristes étaient comme nous on
pleurait presque de voir ces deux
candidats détester et donc au final
l'amérique ne veut pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
j'ai peur de l'élection de 2020 à quel
match
j'ai du mal à l'imaginer imaginer
comment les candidats s'inspireront de
trump et de sa boîte à outils et
j'espère et je prie pour que l'élection
ne soit pas aussi vulgaire et aussi
négative que celle de cette année
cette élection était dégradante et
déprimante
le niveau était si bas si pitoyable
aller avec un pur chanson à rené
lections plus raisonner la prochaine
fois quel que soit le vainqueur en 2016
l'amérique aura montré sa colère sa
violence ses divisions et un show
politique comme jamais auparavant dans
ce monde impitoyable dans lequel nous
sommes tous le gentleman de
l'information dan rather reste pourtant
optimiste je voudrais bilan que quel que
soit le résultat de cette élection
la question sera la suivante où est ce
que le vainqueur donald trump ou hillary
clinton et vous parviendra à convaincre
les américains de regarder vers la
vierge notre destinée à nous les
américains a toujours été de regarder au
delà de l'horizon un jeu est ce que le
prochain président après cette campagne
souvent ridicules et parfois
complètement délirante parviendra à
rassembler le pays
parviendrons nous à avancer comme nous
l'avons toujours fait je parie du oui
les yeux
[Musique]